[Musique]
ce verger en place sur 2100 m² environ
et abrite notamment une grande
collection de pommiers environ 350
variétés et à peu près 230 variétés
différentes de poires
[Musique]
ce verger existait déjà en partie à
l'époque des moines chartreux qui était
à cet emplacement ici avant la
Révolution donc c'est moins Chartreux
cultivait beaucoup de variétés
différentes de pommiers Poirier pêcher
abricotier vigne également c'est moins
de Chartreux ont été délogés à la
Révolution le site a quand même
réaménagé au 19e siècle pour créer une
nouvelle pépinière sous le Second Empire
Auguste rivière a dessiné le verger tel
qu'on le connaît aujourd'hui donc on est
en 1866 à peu près ce verger du coup a
essayé de retrouver toutes ces variétés
des moines chartreux
ce jardin est traité de complètement de
manière biologique aucune molécule de
synthèse en tout cas on va essayer
d'accueillir aussi au maximum les
insectes auxiliaires donc ce sont pour
les plus connus et l'herbe de coccinelle
qui vont manger les pucerons
on dispense des cours pour le grand
public donc on a un cycle de formation
arboricole notamment au Pavillon d'avion
à côté pour les cours théoriques et sur
le terrain ici en hiver où les gens vont
apprendre à tailler à greffer
la récolte du verger donc sert déjà en
priorité à faire connaître les variétés
anciennes donc le but c'est de faire des
expositions de fruits les plus
emblématiques ou les plus rares ensuite
on va stocker ces fruits dans une
chambre froide et ils sont destinés à la
soupe populaire du 6e arrondissement de
Paris